when we are in the proximity of sin when
we're in the throws of lust or gluttony
or whatever well first of all again I
don't want to bring us all the way back
to a met meta ethical conversation but
you would need to even substantiate that
sin is a real thing that exists and that
it's your and it's the sin that you
believe and it's the actions that you
believe in that are sin and not any
other religions you need to deduce that
via reason and evidence and then after
you establish that could you only then
say that being in near instance of sin
is but you you don't even make that l
do do you think that some things are
better or worse than other things yeah
okay so then we agree that there is such
a thing morality as morality and there's
such a thing as virtue and there's such
a thing as morality there's such a thing
as virtue but if you're telling me that
and therefore sin too